in this video you're going to learn how
to write an interval notation where the
graph is increasing decreasing and
constant and we're going to go through
five examples together so let's dive
into this video first of all what do we
mean when we say the graph is increasing
or decreasing or constant well
increasing it's like reading a book when
you read from a left to right you're
looking at where is the graph going up
to the right it's almost like it has
like a positive slope in a sense it
doesn't have to be a a constant slope
but it's going up to the right we say
that's increasing decreasing we say it's
like like going downhill like as reading
from left to right going down down down
to the right that's called decreasing
and then constant means it's like a
horizontal line so it has like a slope
of zero like that now if you don't
remember anything at all from this video
the most important thing to remember is
you don't want to include the end points
of the interval because what's happening
is when the graph is changing from
increasing to decreasing or decreasing
to increasing or decreasing to constant
whenever it's changing that particular
point where it's changing you don't want
to include it because it's kind of like
it's switching you know from increasing
to decreasing or one of the other types
so I'll show you what I mean let's go
through some examples together so for
number one what I would do is I would
scan from left to right just like I'm
reading a book and I'd say oh I can see
the graph is going up to the right so
that tells me it's increasing and I'll
just draw an up Arrow here to abbreviate
increasing and that's for what x values
are the y values increasing so for what
x values are the Y values going up up up
well that's going to be from negative
infinity
to1 and again
remember open interval you don't want to
include the end points because here
at1 you can see the graph is like is it
constant is it increasing is it
decreasing it's it's it's switching
right basically at this point now where
is the graph
decreasing well again reading from left
to right right the graph is going down
down down so we're basically saying for
what x values are the Y values
decreasing and that's going to be from
-1 to positive
infinity and again open intervals and
then where is the graph constant I'll
just draw like a horizontal line to
abbreviate constant there's really
nowhere on this graph where the graph is
going horizontal so we'll just say none
for
that okay let's go to the next one
number two so what do you think on this
one where is the graph increasing
decreasing or constant well again
reading kind of like a book from left to
right okay uh you can see that okay the
graph's going up to the right so as X
values for what x values are the yv
values increasing well that's from
negative Infinity to positive one so
negative Infinity to positive one not
including one because once you get to
one you can see now we have a horizontal
line so it's going to be
constant from 1 to two again not
including the end points so open
interval and then once you get to two
it's going down to the right that's like
kind of like a negative slope it's
decreasing so for what x values are the
Y values decreasing that's from two
onward or we could say two to
Infinity okay what do you think for
number three where is a graph increasing
decreasing constant now this one's a
little bit more challenging so
increasing I always think of like a
slope like a positive slope so I know
like up to the right up to the right so
basically from here and here these two
little regions it's increasing so what
we're going to do for increasing on this
one is we're going to say from one sorry
negative one to
zero okay it's increasing but also from
one onward it's increasing so we're
going to put the U for
Union and we have two intervals United
Okay together make sure you work from
left to right like low to high now
where's the graph decreasing meaning
it's going down to the right kind of has
like a negative slope we can see here
it's going down to the right here it's
going down to the right so again two
intervals and so for what x values are
the Y values decreasing that's going to
be from negative Infinity to negative
one again not including the end points
Union from zero see this now see here's
where students make a mistake they
sometimes look at the Y values to say oh
it's decreasing from uh from two down to
zero those are the yv values so I always
say to myself for what x values are the
Y values decreasing so the y- values are
going down between 0er and one again
using an open interval it doesn't
include zero doesn't include one because
at those points it's then changing
direction and is there any place on this
graph where it's horizontal or constant
no it would look something more like
this like a horizontal line so let's do
two more examples together maybe you can
pause the video and try these on your
own for some practice and and let's look
at those next okay so what do you think
for number four and five where is the
graph increasing decreasing or constant
in interval notation see if you can do
these and while you're doing that I just
want to let you know if you like the way
that I explain things I've got video
courses for sale on Algebra 1 and
algebra 2C col algebra and what's neat
about these courses is that sometimes in
my videos you know I highlight some of
the you know important Concepts but
there's some connecting Concepts
sometimes that don't get covered in my
YouTube videos or even in other YouTube
videos because people are highlighting
oh how to complete the square or how to
graph a parabola but sometimes there's
some little in between I would say kind
of like connectors that help you to
build from one concept onto the next and
those are the types of things that I
talk about in the courses as well as
those key Concepts as well building one
concept on top of the to the next so if
you like the way I explain things check
out those courses for sale video uh
links in the description and what do you
think for number four and number five
now so uh where is the graph increasing
now another analogy that might help you
is imagine you're driving a car okay so
here's your little car okay and you
drive the car from left to right like
this across the graph so you can see
that it makes sense that we're going
downhill right and so that means okay
that's decreasing that's decreasing here
the car is going up to the right like
it's going uphill okay kind of like the
roller coaster here so it looks like
it's inreasing
from1 to 0 so for what x values are the
Y values going up that's from -1 to 0er
again remember open intervals where is
the graph decreasing well you can see
from negative Infinity toga 1 remember
we're using the X values and then Union
also from zero onward so we can say from
zero to positive Infinity again don't
want to be confused and say oh from four
to negative Infinity or negative
Infinity to four those are the Y values
we're saying for what x values are the
Y's going down down down down okay for
number five what did you get for this
one where is a graph increasing
decreasing or
constant well again you want to think
about going from left to right and think
about this graph is going if it's up to
the right it's increasing down to the
right decreasing horizontal constant
what's interesting about this graph is
we've got some asmp tootes see these
dashed or dotted lines so the graph's
going to get closer to those Asm tootes
but it's not going to touch not going to
cross so here it looks like it's
increasing basically from negative
Infinity to
2 okay not including two and then what
happens is we jump way down here and it
goes up up up up to the right again so
that means for what x values are the Y
values increasing well again that's
going to be from 2 to POS Infinity so we
have a little Gap here because the
vertical Asm toote but in this case the
graph is basically always going up to
the right it's just that it's in these
two branches and so it's never
decreasing never going down to the right
never horizontal so great job if you're
able to follow these five examples if
you want some more practice if you want
to test yourself and do some more
problems or you just want to see some
more explanation follow me over to
another video I did talking about the
same concept increasing decreasing
constant and I'll see you over in that
video